I don't know if you know this like don't
don't tell Ryan but
um Filipinos are the Mexicans of the
world you don't think I knew that I'm
the Mexican of this world
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to
another awesome episode of the careful
boys where we are currently off the
Record and we have Mr Walter Hong here
wow
and uh operation get Walter married
what's going on man because I'm old and
so uh how old are you now I'm 49. oh wow
look really very good moisturize I
moisturize yeah um but I'm old and uh
you know my parents are obviously
getting older as well and so um I think
one of the things like as your parents
get old you know if you're single they
they don't want you to be alone you know
and so
um so you know the added stress of all
that you know so I'm like you know what
my friend calls me and goes hey I think
I have a message from God and she's not
even Christian I was like okay cool
um I think we used to go to Korea and
try to find like a wife in Korea so it's
like cool you guys gonna go on a Korea
trip together we're gonna go we're gonna
go in uh uh April this was a message
from God this is what she said but she
slamming Christian so I don't know where
it's like Rich God you're like a
missionary to go get missionary
something like that yeah
it'd be like if I made up a facade and
I'm going to Korea is she calling like
Ayahuasca God or something I don't know
like what like when she said I don't
know if she meant like God God or if she
meant just like the proverbial
figurative God like I don't know what
whatever I didn't I didn't question it
got it I was just like cool god let's do
it
um so yeah we're going to Korea in April
and then um I signed up for uh like the
dating because I have a friend that got
engaged in Korea and so she's like kind
of helping me out and guiding me like
navigating through all that like how do
you find your partner is there like a
dating so they have Tinder and Bumble
there and so those are the it was like I
guess the bigger ones and then Tinder is
similar to here other except that they
also have a lot more people that are
looking for long-term relationships on
Tinder
um oh but the difference the main
difference for me uh between like
because you can if you pay for Tinder
and Bumble you can change your location
and they'll say oh he's doing travel
mode but if you don't pay for you can't
do that so I had a business travel mode
the same thing as like hosing different
area codes type like talk
I I suppose if you're just looking yeah
if you're just looking to hook up you're
preemptively setting the things kind of
right how's your Korean skills it's it's
better than a friend of mine who's a
translator so I feel confident oh oh
cool oh wow if I was a translator he was
in the military and then he had gone to
uh Korea to be a translator even though
he's not Korean at all yeah so I feel
like the my Koreans is better than his
really I don't want to mention anyone's
names dude I'm gonna mention anyone's
name I don't want to give him away
I'll give you I'll give you his initials
though Bart Quan uh yeah but yeah no
there's a lot of barkles that is true
that is yeah if you Google is like 17
000. hey Quan is a Korean name it is
yeah as well yeah yeah um but you know
the big the main difference between
dating apps like with me doing travel
mode is I'm getting matches
like out here I get like zero to one per
like month I mean isn't the stat like
Asians are the the most left swiped on
dating apps yes Asian men Asian men it's
[__] up Asian men have the highest
like rejection yeah Asian women are the
highest uh most responded to wow they're
the least responded to and then number
two a little side note yeah at least uh
the second least responded to are are
black women so there's a subculture of
Asian men and black women that hook up
I'm telling you it's a good match dude
right yeah because top two top two
should always get together top bottom
two yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
uh hip on bottom uh sorry that was a
call back to another episode which I'm
not supposed to do but I did it anyway
[Laughter]
so are you trying to find a wife in
Korea through the app or is there like a
wife in Korea type service where they
like kind of line it all out or should
they have these uh matchmaking services
in Korea which I I heard pretty pricey
like they're into the thousands of
dollars but it's supposed to be like you
fill out this long questionnaire they
ask you Financial questions they ask you
personality questions and all that and
then
of course it's Asia it's Asia so they
match you up with compatibility but I've
been finding out that a lot of companies
don't actually do that they just go oh
you're single she's single boom let's
match them up and they don't tell anyone
revolutionary yeah and then people the
automatic assumption is we're compatible
so you already start off on the right
foot so I'm like I'm not going to pay
thousands of dollars it's like a placebo
compatibility exactly I'd rather just do
the app and pay like 80 bucks you know
it's fair yeah that's actually true the
apps are hilarious though yeah I wonder
if the e-harmony still works because I
remember that their whole pitch was we
want to create like the best matches by
having the best profile and you can see
each other's profile or something right
I've seen eHarmony work in real life
dude me too how I have I had my friend
Mike Japanese Mike his older brother's
best friend uh had a hard time finding
like a lady on eHarmony he uh met the
lady
they got married I think within a month
like they just clicked wow the month
right after this [__] got into a
car accident that flipped his truck oh
he's paralyzed oh oh the lady if I put
myself in her shoes I'm out laters see
you later I've only known you for a
month I can't be having no husband with
no [__] it's peace Harmony yes
she stays
takes care of him wow for the whole year
while he's like coming out of a coma and
all that [__] uh and I was like they
love each other they really love each
other
what's that episode
yeah yeah I have I have family members
that met and they they uh well not they
weren't family before but you know yeah
like they became
he became
always the best place for incestors
a successful marriage story from
eHarmony too that's within my family so
I've heard that it's best to keep it
within the family within the family yeah
kind of Lannister but you know what I
mean just to call A Lannister kind of
how you feel so your your strategy is to
start talking so that when you get to
Korea you'll have dates yeah so set up
dates before I get to Korea
um but it's just you know like getting
matches like for me I don't know about
you guys but for me it's exciting
because like oh I got a match like it's
crazy because it's totally different
um but then like the way they ask
questions it's super direct like how
much you make annoying actually I
haven't gotten asked Financial questions
how long is your penis oh you're talking
to the girls yeah yeah like because you
know you're messaging but I I got one
the other day it's like are you are you
a kind person and like I wrote back
who says no to this question yeah what
does she say yeah and then she's she's
just like answer the question stupid
that's not very kind answer yeah I got I
got one where um
she goes when are you coming to Korea
and I told her and then she goes oh um
I'm not going to be here so she goes why
don't we just like keep in contact for
the next time you come I go she goes
when are you gonna come like when are
you gonna come next like oh I don't know
probably in the summer like June she
goes okay when in June I go I don't know
I haven't set child plans yet well okay
but you don't know when in June I'm like
no I haven't said travel plans so Kevin
just like hit me up basically when it's
near and I go oh she goes but I'm not
going to be here in June so after that
whole thing of like winning I'm not
gonna be here I go where are you going
to be she goes to Europe I go oh where
in Europe her response why because this
is how people have conversations like
yeah you [__] block her ass
and then she was like
um okay be decent
like be it and I'm like what's that mean
oh it's because I'm using Google
translate or some [__] no like no we're
using English actually because a lot of
it a lot of them why she's speaking like
a father like crazy
speak English lady Jesus in Google
Translate yeah she's probably using
Google yeah she hasn't left her country
but she's still a father
you have to speak in Korean what the
[__] dude some some girls I do want to
tell them that like hey just speaking
Korean because I'm not understanding
because you're turning me off ladies is
that how your friend
um found like a partner from Korea is
like they went through the dating apps
there she did it through the dating app
um so she found a husband and that's so
much easier for women though yeah so and
then it helps that you know she's a half
breed and she's hot so she found someone
rather quickly so she was having trouble
dating even though she's hot because in
Korea because her Korean is not good at
all like she doesn't know Korean so she
used the dating app to like meet people
because she wants a Korean dude she
wanted yeah oh but obviously like you
know she puts that she doesn't speak
Korean so the guy has to be you know
aware and honest with himself like oh
can I communicate with her and so she
found her fiance spoke English oh so
he's oh okay so like they're able to
communicate but like it's same with me
like I put like I'm not good at speaking
Korean so the girl is gonna have to know
how to speak English somewhat but like
one girl I match with she told me like I
don't speak English well I go that's
cool like I'm cool using you know the
translate app or whatever and then she's
like Okay cool so like that's fine but
like the questions that they asked there
as opposed to here and like what's
acceptable is like a little bit
different like I'm noticing like you
know like for instance like that one
girl she's an extreme of like where in
Europe we're gonna go like if you're
gonna go to a continent you can tell me
like which country you're gonna go to
I'm not gonna like stalk you or what if
what if her in her mind when she asks
are you decent that's the same thing as
saying are you prude no she didn't ask
are you decent she said no let's be
decent she was think she was accusing me
of being mean to her like being mean to
her like asking like well like you know
when I ask like where in Europe are
going to be and then she goes like oh
why and then I said well this is so she
can ask you these questions but you
can't ask her you stop being sarcastic
dude
and so yeah that that's but like the but
for me like the biggest difference is
like the matches like the fact that I'm
getting more than one match I'm like wow
like it's already already been an
amazing feeling so even if I don't go
out with any of them I I feel good like
you know what I mean like I got matches
because here it's like like I don't know
if you guys have ever been on a dating
app um it's like no matches
I remember during covid
um I was getting matches and then
they're just trying to get me to join
their only fans
I was like man you wasted so much time
but I'll check it out but I didn't buy
it you're being nice
what's your ideal um girl that you're
looking for then subscriber someone that
says yes I I feel like that's a good
start what someone says yes to dating
you should like have dinner with me you
know or like are you really like are you
really like no you know like
I've noticed okay as I've gotten older
like let's say like when you're younger
like in your 20s and 30s you have let's
say like 20 or 50 things you're looking
for in a woman or a partner
older at least for me that that 20 this
is 25 or 50 it gets smaller and smaller
and it whittles down to let's say like
15. but then those 15 you really want
whereas like when the 2550 if they
didn't have a few you're like okay
that's cool no big deal but now if my
list is probably boiled down to like
five or seven things that I really want
oh yeah they're deal breakers do you
have a do you have an actual list of
whatever
I don't remember all seven of them but
like one of them is just like because no
I have to think about it but like uh
like a deal breaker
like warm big girls are pretty warm I I
don't mean like in terms of a blanket
warm oh because girls are always cold
and they're always complaining about how
cold they are and I'm like dude it's hot
Joe's got a point because that is I want
a girl that runs hot dude I I dated one
it's not fun dude yeah or you run cold I
run hot and so she ran hot too it was
just like cuddling it's like drips of
sweat you need the opposite actually
yeah you need you need the opposite uh
but like yeah someone who has a warm
personality decent and like genuinely
like when I say nice I mean like nice to
everyone because you know people say I
wanna like girls will say this I want a
nice boy okay but then I asked him well
do you want a boy that's nice to
everybody or just you and then they go
just me well that's not a nice boy
that's just the guy that wants to get in
your pants yeah yeah that's cool like I
want a girl that's nice to everyone like
that's genuinely nice you know
um someone that like I feel like is
smart intelligent she doesn't have to be
like the smartest or the most but she's
dumb you can't be dumb triple digit IQ
yeah yeah because if you do it like you
know when you fight with your girlfriend
things just come out you don't mean them
but if I'm dating a dumb girl I feel
like what'll come out is dude are you
stupid and you mean it yeah and then
like you can't recover from that you
can't recover but main calling is good
though what was that name calling is
good name calling is cool yeah
especially when they know you're just
mad yeah but if she's really dumb and
then you say are you stupid it it only
doesn't work if they are that yeah
because I called you a dumb [__] all
the time but she's but she's [__]
smart yeah so it makes it even funnier
when I call her dumb [__] yeah yeah
yeah dumb but she really is a dumb [__]
and I can't say that and then it takes
my fun away the syllables you emphasize
do you care how much money they make
you know I do but not in possibly not in
the way you might be thinking like um
she makes more than you no I don't you
know honestly I don't care if she makes
more or that but what I care about more
so like like the beyond the money like
big picture wise is do we need each
other like I If if I like if I meet a
girl and she's like I make my own money
I don't need you well okay yeah you
don't need my money but then you're
basically what I'm hearing is you don't
need me it's nice to be a team exactly
like so if you if you're codependent you
need each other to me that's a
relationship and I know people may
disagree they may say oh I'm independent
cool do your thing then be by yourself
yeah yeah I agree with that because it's
like there's nothing wrong with
codependence and depending on each other
for different things because you're a
team like if you're thinking about
long-term marriage and everything else
then at that point it's like what's the
point of fighting for Independence so
hard yeah or not so much needing each
other but like do we make each other
better as a team right yeah that's
included this includes well like yeah do
we make each other better because when
once you become a couple
from that point on you're no longer
um like you're a unique version of
yourself based on that other person yeah
like you're you're no longer what your
your trajectory is all different now and
the US is more important than what I
used to want exactly you know because I
hear people talk about like you know I
was in a relationship and I didn't like
it because I couldn't do what I wanted
like well but it's not all about you
because now you have another partner and
so it's about both of you yeah so now I
don't like that then be single yeah do
you care if she has a kid already
so I had a conversation with my mom
about like what threshold is of what she
would care about you know I'll rephrase
Ryan's what he's really trying to ask is
if the girl didn't have a kid that had a
loose [__] but a girl had a kid by the
tightest [__] which one would you
choose
that's what you meant welcome you're
welcome I would choose I would choose
whichever one said yes
no I think you know but the kid things
like that kid thing okay I brought the
divorce thing you know and my mom said
like divorce she's like you know okay
because she understands that at my age
and the women that I'd be dating their
age you know it's inevitable with the
kid she kind of paused and said you know
what but if you guys are in love with
each other like what could I really say
right at that point as long as she's not
a widow
[Laughter]
there's a thing of like okay divorcee or
what about if the woman was never
married but her fiance left her at the
altar oh that's very technical it's very
it's like you know we're like because I
think what did she do wrong you need to
ask him why especially our parents our
parents have no problems victim blaming
yeah no problem so though exactly like
what did she do wrong what's wrong with
her why is she so annoying it
immediately go hmm so it's it's she must
be the problem yeah clearly that is so
true though so yeah I think like to me
like I'm open to it of course if I had a
choice all things being equal yeah you
know I want the like you know when it's
ever been married no kids Virgin of
course
you don't mind uh like becoming a dad
like they really that's pretty cool if I
were to be like a I want to be a dad
yeah but the same time I know my
physical limitations like if I'm
watching Korean dramas for 20 minutes
and I get up to go pee everything hurts
like joints hurt yeah like everything
hurts dude huh your dick hurts too
that's chlamydia
actually chlamydia is the painless one
it's syphilis and gonorrhea wow so for
you instead of getting a puppy you
rather go to the pound and get one
that's about 10 years old no actually I
do get puppies
you know it's just what about what about
faith and like religion yeah for yeah
someone who's a Believer like who's
Christian
um what if she goes to the unification
Church
like the Moonies the Circle K people
well at least she'll have a cool gun
collection
yeah I know when you when you get into
okay so as I've as I'm older is one
thing is like
we think like oh yeah these people think
the same but it's they're to the outside
like they're the same but when you're
inside if they're off the mark by a
little bit
that creates big problems
you know so like they'll say like Oh
Yeah from the outside oh yeah they're
all Christian
but then it's like when you're inside
it's like no but they're the unification
church it's a little off the mark but
from the outside it's the same but yeah
we're like oh Christian yeah Baptist
Catholics what's the difference it's all
good it's all the you know so I think
it's yeah as I've gotten older I've
gotten more particular which is probably
people think oh you're picky but it's
just but you also know what you want
more yeah so how did you go to Korea and
you meet somebody right let's say you
got like seven things and this chick's
got like six
yeah dude if she had two I'd be okay oh
I I honestly at this point like the
biggest concern for me is this is where
do we live right because
um before like in the 80s 90s and early
odds a lot of Koreans wanted to move to
America but not Korea's soul is like
thriving there's no reason to move to
America so I have to find a niche girl
that hates her life in Korea that hates
her job these U.S citizenship yeah and
it wants to come over here exactly but
like a girl that like is like a head of
marketing she's like I want to come here
all right right right but like a girl
that like you know works like a 10 to 10
job
you know like on her feet all day maybe
she wants to be a cattle rancher in
America what if she that'll be dope what
if she works at KFC in Seoul that would
be perfect and then she would hate KFC
here because the KFC there is better
because he's better chicken but yeah
it's it's you know so I think about
these things where like if I find like a
girl that's like highly educated and has
a great job she's not gonna want to come
here right they're going to want a movie
are you are you looking specifically for
a Korean girl at for this trip yes he's
going to create a look for a Filipino
girl
I don't know if you know this like don't
don't tell Ryan but
um Filipinos are the Mexicans of the
world
you don't think I knew that I'm the
Mexican of this world no Ryan he's
carrying this team
but yet on the apps there's a lot of
foreign women that live in Korea that
are on the apps oh cool you're open I'm
open but if I had a choice like if you
know yeah I I choose Korean because you
know what there's there's less
explanation that has to happen I see
yeah it looks yeah I did it a white girl
and she couldn't my house she knew the
shoes thing so she was cool but then she
would like in her outside clothes
she would like lay in my bed and I'm
like and I don't want to be that guy
that's like hey we just sat in the beach
and it's dirty and now you're gonna go
into it's like like a Korean girl would
never do that she would never do this is
more like culturally a lifestyle Harmony
there's no explanation like for instance
example like you know we're all Asian
here we know that when there's a platter
of food we let the parents eat first
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like white
people or like different cultures they
may not have that doesn't mean they're
bad people it's just it's a culturally
they don't have it yeah it means they're
monsters
disgusting people like Sacramento people
yeah yeah
but like for certain things like that
how much of that is like I don't say a
deal breaker but is is it conflict it's
not a deal breaker it's just more like
it's just like hey like I'm open to
different ethnicities and different
races and all that but if I had a choice
I'd rather select the girl that I don't
have to explain things but of course
like dude if I fall in love with like um
you know whatever some Swedish girl
that's like blonde hair oh God forbid
that happens yeah right but then she's
like I have to wear my shoes in the
house
all right like you know yeah because
you're hot cool
everybody looks hot in those shoes
anyway but if she's Korean it's easier
for them to get along with your parents
or at least have a conversation yeah so
it's there's more of the family bonding
yeah like I consider that stuff like
that just stick to your kind dude I
think it's gonna be easy yeah stick to
your damn kind stick to my own animal
Animal Kingdom
well good luck dude thank you true luck
man let's go get it come back married
none of us are preserving our cultures
thank you